this is the third white in a row I'm
going to go with D for again and see if
we're going to still get into lines from
the World Championship I've been
learning a lot because by reviewing
those games I do try to be as exact as
possible with the things i'm sharing
because i know it does end up reaching
quite a few people and i upload but well
even if that wasn't the case i just i'm
kind of like that I just really want to
make sure everything I'm saying is
accurate and I'm learning things along
the way when I'm doing that so we are in
Game two in Game four how might if we
still follow suit here no we didn't have
that f3 i already know i'm i looked over
this with the computer i know that f3 is
a strong reply and now this is something
i was emphasizing in that game this if
the bishop does come out early this idea
of taking and then queen bee three so
why am I not doing it right away I Hardy
I already did my homework on this line I
should just be rattling those moves off
quicker let's go troublesome for black
now sometimes they'll be a situation
with the night could play to c6 and
after Queen takes Knight B for looking
at sea too but with this pond still not
moved there is not that a possibility so
what do you do here i think i could play
g4g 5 and then take on this square
Bishop b5 has just met with knight c6 i
don't know if that's really
accomplishing a whole lot g4 is heading
in the direction of taking out d5 and
then being up upon and welcoming a queen
exchange so what am i getting at let's
go here g4
a very committal move but it will earn
me upon and I believe what is very close
to just being Queen trade as well so
let's see what's the scoop here what is
that scoop hmm
well I don't know what to suggest for
black they might be considering let's
say some minor piece sacrifice but
that's not really working you know if if
that's being chewed on right now
something bishop or Knight takes and
Queen takes one of the pieces ending up
on this square I still have Queen takes
b7 or queen takes d5 and it's I think
it's trouble in every variation for
black
okay deep think my opponent is tanking
right here think Tankian I don't my my
thought is just bishop g6 but maybe
something else is being considered I
really don't know or are how about this
no Bishop Bishop e6 defends the pond
it's very awkward for this guy's
development but maybe that was actually
best why am I thinking Bishop g6 Bishop
here I guess that's the way to maintain
the d5 pawn and yeah maybe that should
have been played is there something I
could do instead of just this h4
threatens a trapping of this Bishop I
think however after h4 there's just h6
and the bishop is saved and I can't do
g5 anymore my ruck would be hanging
after a pond capture so I think it's
just this g5 there's no Knight move here
this pond is watching over me for has to
go to the edge or go home neither one is
good no good no good solution from here
on out I don't think as soon as that
deep on is no longer I just have a move
like a four and it's just really showing
you know the advantage in the center
that extra pond is really showing so
it's with the Queen I believe that I
should I should be taking welcoming a
queen exchange up upon she can't go too
far if she goes to the C file might as
well premium of this she goes to the c5
Bishop d2 and rook to see one
okay I'm okay with this exchange I'm
okay with most exchanges at this point I
might want to not play e4 because it
does allow for a night move to f4 at
some point hmm I'll just fish up here
Castle what is blacks most annoying
piece see if I play here there's Bishop
to d6
I really just want to keep this really
clean here I just I'm up a pond I want
to keep keep it clean avoid
complications how can I avoid
complications night here night 2 g-3
it's just so I could get this move in
seems like he's not doing anything right
now but I really would like to get this
structure in to stop this Bishop from
seeing things and then I have a good
spot for my dark square Bishop i'm going
to give that a shot I'd be quite all
right with the GG puns because my Rick
comes to life that happens i also have
to watch out for eight the H file
opening up with my pawn on d5 there
could be h 6 in this rook and start to
have an influence so I'd like to avoid
that may be what else I guess bishop d
cigs rip to c8 Bishop e7 okay I guess
fearing and night b5 move did I have
that available could that have caused a
black and inconvenience i think and i
guess it could have but i think this is
fine too i'm ok i'm not thinking at all
about kingside castle a king on f 2 is
fine especially if Bishop d6 is played
up smoking f2 and then i'll look into
night take ok now i have the H file ok
my Knights pinned but I'm not too
concerned about that I think this is the
way to go here or you know what now let
me just break that pin right away
reserved this ponds move could even look
into f four stops this e 5 break
and who you know what I want to avoid
office of color bishops how can I avoid
opposite color bishops on push yeah
let's let's shut that down i'm looking
for a 3 next maybe i don't know if this
is the cleanest approach now it's not
going to be opposite color bishop so i'm
going to take like this and if night
a4ai play king to d2 and then finally
get my light squared Bishop out ok I
have to take like that and pond up
because I want to play this move now
let's just go here I can do a pond push
but I'm not going to do that it's going
to defend here there's no time really
for black so I did the a4 moon let me
just take I did the a4 move just so i
could play rippy one and not have to
deal with the pond on b5 but yeah that
was a serious time disadvantage right
that I was getting a bit elaborate with
what it is I was wanting to do
forgetting that is probably just going
to end on time but ok good game let me
back up here this is something that I do
reference in two different videos no no
just one video about bringing the Queen
bishops out too early on the black side
game number game number two of the World
Chess Championship I talked about that
Bishop coming out early so this is a
problem now because of queen bee three
maybe it's best at this point after g4
that you bring your Bishop back to
preserve that pond but certainly very
very awkward to have to do that so the
idea here is to not develop that light
square Bishop on g4 or even f5 looking
into e6 is probably best right here e 6
night decent 97 depending on what I do
in my beep on again a lot of this is
referenced from the recent are the
excuse me the ongoing world chess
championship